Yves Giroux, bonjour,
merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation.
- Ça me fait plaisir.
- M. Giroux, on a eu l'occasion
de discuter de votre mandat
en période électorale, en 2019,
dans le cadre d'une élection
qui était à date fixe.
Est-ce que c'est différent
de vérifier les promesses
des partis politiques quand
l'élection vous arrive comme ça,
de façon imprévue?
- Le travail en lui-même est
essentiellement le même.
La grande différence, c'est
qu'on peut pas se préparer
de la même façon que lorsque
les élections sont à date fixe.
Et on n'a pas la même durée,
aussi, pour évaluer l'ensemble
des promesses qui nous sont
soumises. Parce qu'il faut bien
le dire, c'est à la demande
des partis politiques
qu'on estime le coût de
leurs promesses électorales.
Donc, plutôt que d'avoir
120 jours, période au cours
de laquelle on peut le faire
pendant une élection à date
fixe, on a uniquement du moment
où la campagne électorale est
déclenchée jusqu'au moment
des élections. Dans ce cas-ci,
36 jours, ce qui est beaucoup
moins de temps que 120 jours
en période normale.
- Pour le commun des mortels,
qu'est-ce que c'est votre mandat
en période électorale?
Les partis politiques viennent
vous voir et vous disent :
est-ce que ça a du bon sens,
ce que je suis en train
de promettre?
- Les partis politiques peuvent
venir nous voir pour nous
demander d'estimer le coût
de leurs promesses électorales,
le coût des promesses
qu'ils envisagent de faire.
Donc, ils nous demandent
uniquement d'estimer le coût
ou les revenus qui seraient
générés par des nouveaux impôts
ou des nouvelles taxes,
par exemple. On leur fournit
les estimations de coûts.
S'ils prévoient toujours
annoncer ces mesures-là,
ils nous avertissent, ils nous
informent lorsque la mesure est
annoncée, et à ce moment-là,
on divulgue publiquement
l'estimation de coût.
Dans le cas où les partis
politiques ne procèdent pas
à l'annonce de quelque chose
qu'ils ont demandé d'estimer,
on doit garder ça confidentiel.
Donc, on ne peut pas divulguer
les renseignements pour lesquels
les promesses ne sont pas
rendues publiques.
- Donc, c'est comme si
c'était jamais arrivé.
- En effet!
- Vous ne pouvez pas me dire
qui vous a déjà demandé
de vérifier quoi. Pouvez-vous
me dire combien de demandes,
indépendamment des partis,
combien de demandes vous avez
reçues jusqu'ici?
- Bien je peux vous parler
de l'exercice de 2019,
au cours duquel on avait reçu
environ 200 demandes au total.
- Quand même.
- Oui, c'est beaucoup.
On en avait publié 115. Donc,
il y a 115 de ces demandes-là
qui avaient été publiées
ou promesses qui avaient été
faites. Et donc, environ
85-90 qui n'avaient jamais été
mises de l'avant par les partis
pour diverses raisons. Ils n'ont
pas l'obligation de nous donner
les raisons pour lesquelles
ils ne sont pas allés.
Pour l'exercice actuel,
étant donné que c'est
un exercice confidentiel
qui n'est pas encore complet,
je peux pas vous dire le nombre
de demandes. Pas encore.
Mais je peux vous dire qu'on est
très, très occupés depuis
que la campagne électorale a été
déclenchée.
- Combien ça prend de temps,
passer à travers une promesse,
analyser une promesse...
une promesse d'un parti X?
- Ça dépend toujours de
la promesse. Si on dit qu'on va
augmenter un taux d'impôts
existant ou baisser un taux
d'impôts existant, c'est assez
facile à faire parce qu'on a
des... des programmes ou
des modèles qui nous permettent
d'estimer ça. Mais si on parle
d'instaurer un nouveau
programme, comme par exemple
un programme national
d'assurance médicaments,
que le NPD a annoncé vendredi,
donc là, ça prend beaucoup plus
de temps. Ça peut prendre
quelques semaines, dans les cas
les plus complexes. Par exemple,
si on n'a pas les données déjà
au bureau, s'il faut qu'on aille
chercher les données ailleurs
et si on n'a pas de modèle
existant pour estimer
une proposition en particulier.
- Dans un contexte comme ça,
vous utilisez les ressources que
vous avez ou vous allez chercher
des ressources supplémentaires?
- On utilise les ressources
qu'on a déjà. On est
une quarantaine au bureau,
dont une bonne trentaine
qui sont en mesure de faire
ce genre d'analyses-là.
On peut aussi demander l'aide
de la fonction publique,
soit pour avoir des données,
accès à des données dont
on ne dispose pas encore ou
encore de l'aide pour estimer
certaines propositions.
Donc, on peut avoir recours
à de l'aide extérieure, mais
on essaie de faire la très vaste
majorité du travail à l'interne
pour éviter, évidemment,
des fuites. Parce que c'est
des questions qui sont
particulièrement sensibles
en campagne électorale.
- Vous êtes-vous déjà demandé
qui profitait le plus de
votre travail? Est-ce que
c'est les partis établis,
les plus petits partis?
Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
en tire davantage de bénéfices?
- Je dirais que ceux qui
en tirent davantage de
bénéfices, c'est probablement
les électeurs. Lorsqu'ils voient
les promesses des partis
politiques et qu'ils sont
rassurés à l'effet que
l'estimation de coût a été
faite de manière indépendante
et non partisane, ils peuvent
avoir une plus grande certitude
que c'est les meilleurs
"estimés" possible. Mais il y a
aussi les partis... Basé sur
l'expérience de 2019, je peux
pas dire que c'est davantage
les petits partis ou les partis
plus établis. Selon moi,
c'est l'ensemble des partis
politiques, peu importe leur
taille et leurs ressources,
qui en bénéficie.
- Vous avez parlé de l'exercice
en 2019, tout à l'heure,
des 200 quelque analyses
que vous aviez faites.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez appris
de cet exercice-là qui vous a
aidé cette fois-ci?
- Hum... On a appris que
les mots qu'on utilise pour,
par exemple, qualifier
un niveau d'incertitude relié
à l'estimation, peuvent être
mal interprétés. Par exemple,
en 2019, on utilisait
des qualificatifs pour dire
qu'une estimation de coût,
donc le coût auquel on arrivait,
avait un niveau d'incertitude
moyen, élevé ou faible.
Et ça a été mal interprété
dans certains médias ou par
certaines... certaines factions
qui étaient en jeu lors
des élections de 2019 comme
étant un jugement de valeur
sur la proposition elle-même.
Donc, on a appris de ça.
On a appris aussi que
les partis politiques n'arrivent
pas dans une élection avec
le même niveau de préparation
et le même niveau de raffinement
quant au développement de
politiques, quant aux détails
auxquels ils ont réfléchi.
Donc, on a vu qu'un service
comme celui que la loi nous
demande de fournir est très
utile pour certains partis
politiques qui n'ont pas...
qui n'ont pas la capacité
de réfléchir au même niveau de
détail que d'autres par exemple.
- Yves Giroux, merci infinim